de retour au bureau voici ange est
désormais limité voire interdit de
retour du confinement distanciation
oblige
fini les rendez vous entre collègues à
la machine à café ces moments se sont
imposés dans la vie en entreprise depuis
que l'appareil il ya débarqué c'était
dans les années 50 un bouton a tourné et
la machine débite un gobelet et la
boisson désiré chaude ou froide s'est du
même coup l'occasion d'une courte
détente musique douce et vers un marin
ne fera bientôt admettre que le travail
est un plaisir la raison première de
l'invasion des machines à café ce n'est
pas la convivialité les la santé au
travail car à l'époque il n'est pas rare
de boire 1 litre on sur le chantier
comme au bureau en 1961
selon l'institut national de sécurité
l'alcool est responsable de 15 % des
accidents du travail graves en relation
avec le temps l'espace machine à café
est devenue une bulle dans l'entreprise
être au travail sans tout à fait y être
pour quelques instants
comme le raconte cette employée en 2006
c'est un petit moment de détente
on prend un café n'oublions parle un peu
de différentes choses de la journée un
peu un peu de sport de la famille de la
vie et du temps perdu dans une journée
de travail
pas tout à fait dans cette même
entreprise la direction note moins
d'absentéisme du personnel et plus
d'efficacité
bien que ce ne soit pas le but initial
force est de constater que
le salarié est ici chez lui donc à
l'aise sans contrainte et donc se donne
se donne beaucoup
selon une étude de l'ifop de 2018
la pause-café reste importante pour 84 %
des salariés français et pour 91%
d'entre eux c'est un moment d'échangé
privilégié
quelle que soit la boisson consommée
[Musique]